[Musique]
crochet avant projet super oui
crochet genou le genou de sa berge
ok delà du pavot carrousel
tu mets la tête en arrière et tu te
pousse à
qu est ce qu il yad autres peter pan
crochet genou et tu tournes à l'achat
ensuite tu peut fair l'a fait à six
le ser c'est super je vis un autre serre
ça aussi c'est la saison
blanche j'y arriverai jamais dû sûr que
si tu vas y arriver
l'escaladé
en fait comment quand on a pas les
muscles pour faire ça les amuse tout
algérien du tout les payons les muscles
suffisant face
sortez pompiers
là
[Musique]
et s'il y en a un qui appelle la police
pour dire quoi j'ai dépensé 5000 $ dans
un club de strip-tease et des mois
seront même pas ce qui leur est arrivé
avant de vérifier dans le compte en
banque
je crois bien que je vais vous bien ça
va on n'est pas les seuls à faire ça
comment vous croyez que le club va pas
déposer le bilan après 2008
c'est une petite tornade doit être
créatif mais belle je connais une fille
du queens ce qu'il a fait elle s'est
fait arrêter non elle a envoyé ses deux
gosses en fac est ce la coule douce à
miami où elle a ouvert une onglerie da
exactement
qu'on réfléchisse
comme les mecs de wall street tu as vu
ce qu'ils ont fait 1-1 ap ils ont volé
le pognon de tout le monde
les travailleurs ont perdu tout ce
qu'ils avaient et aucun de ces salopards
net aller en taule par un seul tu
trouves ça juste d'ailleurs est ce que
tu penses quand ils viennent au club
c'est de l'argent volé ce avec ce fric
payent leur pipe les fonds de retraite
des pauvres pompiers
j'ai eu une double page une fois sans
déconner en 93 puis cassé la glace j'ai
impressionné
stevie wonder est passé qu'est ce qu'un
mec comme steam qu'elle avait mis dans
un salon champagne j'te jure qu'il n'est
pas aveugle de mai
comment tu peux être aussi doué
je t'ai vu avec tous les styles de mecs
et
j'arrive toujours à leur apporter ce
qu'il veut je suis juste le genre de
fille que tout le monde aime bien